this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbuster
summer
you love being whisked away to the
fantasy worlds of tolkien
henson and all the dead authors estates
that walt disney ripped off
now embark on an epic tale of magic and
romance in the brothers grimm tradition
in that it's bleak depressing and
thoroughly german
the never-ending story journey to a
world of never-ending misery
where the heroes are bullied the
locations need therapy
a desert of shattered hopes the deadly
swamps of
sadness and existence is collapsing in
on itself like a fortnight storm made of
nihilism
the nothing to the point where horses
literally drown themselves in sadness
nanohorse didn't actually drown but it's
the kind of movie that really makes you
think they wanted to
die that
at least would be something
thanks to fantasia's lacks child labor
laws only two small boys and one little
girl will fight against the nothing
there's bastion armed with a magic book
and the bow cut of every young male
protagonist from 1973 to 1998.
he'll all up in his school's creepy
hook-up attic to pull a fanfic 101 into
a self-insert as the savior of the
universe
what a marty stew and saddle up with
you've got a movie oh man too soon
and right along with atreyu a young
warrior from the tiger beat tribe
he'll get himself absolutely wrecked
from start to finish
[Applause]
yet he was still able to overcome
impossible odds and become harry potter
junior in the movie troll
experience a story about the power of
storytelling itself
that's really weak in the storytelling
department
what it's a bunch of random obstacles
that it ends out of nowhere
it's got all the dynamics of a super
mario level but what it lacks in depth
it makes up for in menowankery
because their world is powered by the
imagination of bastian's world
and bastion's world is powered by the
imagination of our world
which in turn sparks the audience's
imagination because we're watching both
of their worlds
joining us all together in a
never-ending
story jerk so grab a sandwich
eat an entire apple core and
curl up under a blanket for one of the
weirdest hits of the 80s
that you mostly remember for the amazing
luck dragon
as in it's amazing luck that the fbi
never seized his computer
i like children you were unconscious
and you talked in your sleep
and rocking out to the dope georgioma
rotor score
but you may not remember that this story
didn't truly end no it had a sequel with
jonathan brandes
a threequel starring jack black and both
of them ignored the second half of the
book it's based on
where bastian becomes a power-hungry
madman that tries to take over the
kingdom
wow that's dark even for this story
let's just end with some happy falcore
[Music]
shots
starring reading lame-o
deep v bing-bong great artween
the wolf who cried boy i'm cork i made a
rocks
as you can see the first time you read
the red wedding
say my name say my name have fun starman
this arm
turbo the racing snail that one goblin
from labyrinth
booby trap
the biggest block of butter we've ever
seen
badly dubbed lines nighthawk this could
be serious
rockbiter gumby mickey mouse
e.t c-3po wait what is this ready player
one
and how your mom watches tv what
that's impossible be confident
i'm trying to watch mom shut up
[Music]
my beautiful dark twisted fantasia
i think i know what killed bastian's mom
salmonella
the name's voice guy epic voice guy
doofenshmirtz evil incorporated
i'm done saying things at the end of
these videos
so stop asking
liar liar pans on fire